hey rocket League fans just like you
guys we are super excited for the world
championship to get underway but while
we wait we decided to put together a
list of the best goals from the North
American Championship Series starting
with this beautiful passing play by
cloud 9 against the legions contained
pressure for cloud 9 Allegiance need to
get challenging guys maybe never pass
play oh sweet as you like
zigzag passing play c9 are now three
goes up you want to talk about work in
the midfield just one side of the field
to the other and you see everybody
rotating back and their last three
meetings including this one rogue has
won one game fire burner uphill drop
another beautiful shot
so pretty it's the most of this Huxley
Jacob Garret the team boys fire burners
is upside down there's a nice passive
Ariel - we like backfield as a shot
comes out Garrett actually missing an
open net by nine with an opportunity 45
seconds left and also small epidemic to
not react a squishy look at the double
tap and they use the quelled nine
special the double tap incident that
cloud9 take the lead against the run of
play a beautiful pass from gimmick man
looking forces drops of fact that man
takes the shot
beautiful one-to-one play there to make
it a three goal game hit Rose turn it
away with game to talk about those
pathways from rogue this is exactly what
I'm talking about a play all the way
downfield
but nets that have been caused gonna
have a lovely pass straight down and tie
will turn that into the net this is the
reason why the level of rocket league is
just things so much better the team that
we expect it to be maybe further down
the leaderboard we talked about them
learning from their previous week shown
that they can view these guys this every
game goes on these guys become more and
more comfortable with this speed with
the speed they're too much to handle and
a beautiful transition from offense to
defense for cloud nine and this has been
a consistent problem for allegiance last
week added this week as well of holding
their opponents Sports one in fury and
squishy are gonna come skipper there is
four men putting that one is in that 15
seconds remaining
and legions can you hold your nose 1 2 2
3 everybody involved pass inside in that
a beautiful touch on that backboard
double commitments on both sides of the
ball for fly quest Sachin you're looking
for Chrome go back into the middle
Sachin you're over the top rub the G up
and he'll put it into the net the pass
plays again coming through for flight
one this was just everyone getting beat
by this chrome beating Matt's a junior
beating says in Seoul not really knowing
how to retreat in time and corrupted
beating him as well he that is
individual play touching the ball they
were going for the 50/50 s but just
getting beaten completely and it just
goes entirely against their favor and so
look for Matt takes the shutdown deal
puts it in immediately gets their three
Goldie back there we go quick and short
insulin Matt back and forth to each
other and now it feels like they're
starting to play together a bit more as
a full triple squad you can see them all
spacing out and getting the position
made it so easy calculated Patrick for
Timmy I'm I'm gonna just go on a limb
and say I think that might be the world
record for a hat-trick and he has a
hat-trick in what is this a minute she's
shot as a bit hike in time finish the
song he puts it back to see past what a
play here from the leeches to get on the
board and here this is where you can see
they're finally starting to pick up the
pace tie dropping that back down just
trying to feed out Timmy endeavor very
well plays just a lot of ball control
right now in enemy territory shot
beautiful placement the widest pass
we've seen yet it still connects I don't
think this was expected to be a pass tie
popped it up thinking Ellucian could
come in and what a beautiful egg you
make just sitting there in the back line
bumping to play oh this is flush right
now
lovely passing place gonna go back to
one more time one two three four cloud9
will you show me more on EE vowel plays
as well and the placement for him to hit
that straight down I don't even think
gimmick expected it to be that perfect
just with the long clears that are
coming through it is waiting for a wide
defensive rotation but here comes cloud
nine with the small ball passing plays
squishy to gimmick them back oh my
goodness they get the win this is what
makes cloud nine
nine squishy two gimmick and instead of
taking this shot you could just see
Rizzo his his the cogs were turning he
wanted him try and figure it out solid
clear same jockey fall into the air over
the top of chrome backed out of the box
left them here in the finishes look at
this pass from st. Jack I wanted to
write off the ceiling to put it down as
fast as possible for his teammates and
Jackie beating Chrome on defense
corrupted GPS in the wrong way
completely crown fire burner with Jacob
to work with over the top and the
defense doesn't matter energy strike you
just have to watch five burners thought
process your knowing who's in front of
him knowing who's behind him side
Phyllis's comes in but he's not able to
get the bump is dude in the middle of
front-flipping they've got in the past
for Novi Garrett G to follow it through
towards the net can he put this one in
Jake upstairs it off Jacob with the
heavy carry this today the one goal game
19 seconds left
NRG has got a chance there's nothing
Rizzo could do unfortunately it seems to
be that both of these teams are kind of
missing that that next rotation that
next man that after the initial shot
draw something out someone who
immediately follow up and put on a shot
put the fake from Jane apps and the
follow-up from chrono V oh my goodness
go the entire and the pitch Jane apps
takes himself out of Jacob but he
respects it doesn't go for the initial
touch goes for the second one instead
but what really counts is the one that
was at the end the sec qualifier and
that was fire burner and company but
they are gone they are done now finish
at third squishy right off the bat here
gonna score for cloud nine and they're
off to the races 20 seconds in and they
are a warmed up team gimmick out you see
this three team passing play all of them
squishy fluttering his boost to get the
perfect shot
the backcourt classist is there makes a
soft touch but let the mirror helps bail
him out since it all the way down the
field could same jackie send this into
the net II can just look at this touch
from let them here as the way he reads
classics it sends it flying down the
field I don't know did it come off
classics yeah that was classics to let
them hear the same Jack that's actually
insane they're all spamming oh my god
enchant ghost it's time to rotate
themselves back same Jackie guess it's
for up to G he's gone sad junior as an
option now they gotta coats the upper
and the pig st. Jackie long left mare we
have to follow he gets in it and Ghost
gaming take Kayla number one they avoid
overtime by one hard clear say Jackie
keeping it high knowing said junior
wouldn't be able to go for D hat no
who's that entire time to another play
away from Ghost gaming they've got
options here off the backboard here
comes same Jeff you want to try make it
to okay how much straight down is so
awkward so this is so ghosts to go lead
a minute half remaining this could be
their time I actually am incredibly
impressed with led Amira
[Applause]
over towards Rizzo the team plays war
nobody expected Rizzo to take that shot
that'll be g2 back in the lead all
starting with that touch from Jana
softly putting it up to the chrono via a
time to look for a teammate and Rizzo
off in that corner all quiet by himself
no need a break oh for the duct tape
just yet gets traffic looks for the
double somebody is gonna get it what a
way for cloud nine to respond in this
game who only 12 seconds a beautiful
pass off field and then right back to
him just a quick one two all in the air
Matt's able to get the follow up touch
uncontested but Jake will look for
Garrett Jeep and you can get the pass
back down it doesn't really go into the
midfield so I'll have to carry himself
gets a pass insulin it looks for fire
burner in that Nam puts it down what I
meant to say was guarantee looking for
the goalie fire burner comes up against
the pass the beautiful place with energy
just continue here that was beautiful
from Garrett if you notice how quickly
he landed on all four wheels and jumped
right back up off the ground it's all in
the middle man we'll send it back up to
try and take a shot passes the system
team play does not work now hopefully
that'll finish it off and they'll get on
the board here just watching this
execution right here shows how good rope
truly is and so out decision and that
stilt support just in case it one of the
post as team oriented as rocket League
is there are times when you got to do it
all by yourself and there's nobody
better than that then Energy's Jacob
funding something way back through those
the very difficult questions got us
under wall he's got options available
and Jacob yet again
gonna take it past absolutely everybody
he goes from being in the most danger he
could be in two just beautiful really
just has to do with Jacob like a lot of
the times we talk about that man who's
first in net because of this man here
the way he's been all Jacob take the
ball and to it sure just watch this one
just one that's disgusting
now firemen are looking to go the other
way Firebird takes his gimmick of being
able to win any challenge and uses it to
score deflected goal a prime example of
the Firebird ninety ten fifty fifty to
the corner this is to fly this one down
Jacob now to play off the ceiling into
the goal all by himself off the ceiling
well done and as the placement the
placement alone the Jacob can pull off
off the ceiling to himself flipping
around and then making shirts objectory
alters all the way in putting it just
under the crossbar never go for the
triple plays from the beautiful play
from down we're just watching dapper he
Newt I was coming on his backside suit
he didn't even go for the jump he just
didn't touch it tie few shots under his
belt but it's still very early and
nobody's scored all my member all the
way down sea bass from his own corner
allegiance has the lead a lot of it has
to do his sea bass playing this
horizontal put that pop just catches a
Jackie completely off same jockey to
carry this one at the beginning of game
two over the top of two putts in it by
himself looking say Jackie go watching
to cope with this I was a bit scared you
saw let the mirror underneath not
expecting a Jackie to get yet another
touch his third one in a row row not
looking confident and Curnow v can turn
it in
it honestly feels like Renova just
stuttered button mashing the flippy hat
there he landed got the flip tapper
they'll get it past the back line put it
through renegades got the lead back
dapper so good at these triples here do
see some minor touches getting enough of
an angle there classics going right past
him Jacob my follow this one upside down
take a shot towards the net puts it in
this there's just nobody else that
follows like this guy right now
and how much [ __ ] I thought when he was
done with this no one won yes one boost
left the moment he made that time sir
gave me midfield clears uncontested and
look at ty not Tyler getting the double
tap off the side wall three goals the
nail in the coffin in game 3 the stat
boost up with this shot gets himself two
shots ago aerials taste what you won off
the ceiling to follow this one through
to try tap it back down it see past the
beautiful subtle of plays Allegiance
three kids in a row strikes first every
single time it is a ludicrous angle see
vas stepping up its period of time what
has been a story all day for these teams
putting the other great place and
wouldn't know what a squishy deacons
Airport just in time before dad Berg was
about to touch him what a play in the
bull cam just really confused me for a
second there but squishy on that wall he
has had some difficulties there in the
past but this time he comes outside that
the shot that double tap there from Jay
naps we are all tied up one game apiece
Jay Nance can't find the goal the first
time or the second time with the third
time he'll make it count but left mere
yet again is stopping that out as a
charter
so we're going to Game five Jane apps is
the talisman here's the ghost scorer and
right now he is the Savior
the intention was to put it back in his
half that they had control but no one
was the net just gave a wide open shot
for Rizzo was the the Gophers are still
a difficult what Joe might goodness the
burn is happening here from G to a
hat-trick now for Jane apps just look at
this solo play set it up for himself all
the way down it on the wall Zane Jack
he'll play to the side Jane have to put
pressure down over the top by himself
off the backboard around all of the
defense it's Jane amps with them we
talked about this is the North American
MVP stuff like this this sort of carry
the NIA has right now for g2 is 100 and
that hit even just into the corner that
set it up
take over [ __ ] still off it's me site
Jacob goes for a flip goes for the call
Jacob that was in other words sublime
gorgeous play coming up from Jacob
reminiscent of last week with that
thought she pinches it off the wall and
then that dribble
no one's hesitating visca meant this
match fire burns the backboard says is
there Albany dropped it right back fire
printer width or a really beautiful
playing in our G's strikes watching this
on fire furnace perspective to get that
first touch on the backboard doesn't no
scissors
oh he actually didn't make any contact I
thought this made any at all rocket
League isn't always about great passing
or individual plays sometimes it's about
proving a point so here are the best of
the bully plays starting with this
insane double demolition play by go
sustain Jackie and yeah I have to say it
will be a mistake
they'll probably finish this one up or
it could be safe Jackie
turning himself into a monster and
gobbling up the entire team this has to
be so frustrating duffle demolition on
defense corrupted G the only one left
moves up now
the top of squishing is the demo under
squishy as well since the drop is one
behind
decisions but he didn't see Matt coming
up and it's all one goal game then
detract with the bird Matt says passing
plays we've seen men how to sit right
back down to match gimmick was there for
this exactly what they need to do they
need to apply this pressure energy keep
them on back in an uncomfortable
position
but unfortunately when they do that
they're leaving their net live it up and
off this is caught the coal when did you
see okay that's two pumps and that's
just me Jacob that's not okay no break
away to the side this game
demolished oh dear that's two players
down cholatse skip this is anybody in
the back no that'll be it all the way
through ghost with 18 seconds left here
in game 3 has the lead and no surprised
ghost gets another demolition goal
classics taking out torment gimmick
there's no way he'd get back in time and
also City Hall right squish just gets
himself a little bit revenge just
immediately goes for one of the teams I
don't care which one it is I'm taking
money off squishy takes the player
bruins the NRG defense and allows
himself to set up for his teammates
these demos are becoming more and more
crucial some angles in rocket league are
nearly impossible to calculate but
somehow see knives gimmick makes it look
easy with the 0 degree goal against fly
quest as if he'd just been up a leave
sad jr. in net go without booth she was
unable to deal back on our tech cloud9
are you kidding me from the corner the
zero degree angle to give them the three
goal lead that was dirty oh my goodness
absolutely dirty he even got underneath
it to pop it out he'll follow himself I
was three players from rogue Peninsula
what ankle is this it doesn't even look
like a shot from the auto camp but want
to watch the replay rolls it up and
follows it himself surprise that works
out too like you said all three players
were committed to them bringing a one be
free play for a moment here and
understandably all my kidding me look at
this shot I honestly thought the
injector was gonna pass this back down
to classic Andy wouldn't get their time
but instead see Jackie just off for I
don't even know do it again since so
cast opportunity and there it is the
rear-admiral for insolence is that if
watch to pop off the wall and it seemed
like it was an uncomfortable jump he
will brick Hubbard what walk clear up
gimmick shot goes and off the side of
his car an oblong angle here but he
makes it a 2o game really full
absolutely bleep full gimmick that is
one heck of an angle of Selectmen
another long ball back into that corner
takes the early shot of water tango that
from lemon and let them hear coming out
strong with this hit just a pass play
back inside to him and falls it up reads
that wall perfectly in and beats use
their chi in the corner here he'll look
to see if we can get it down pass Matt
and awesome it's
are you kidding me what was this I
wonder if in check just like dick thanks
thanks thanks he just smacked it down
really just to put some pressure on do
it it's rocket league's best double taps
and one touches are all up next just
boi-ing enough to carry across the side
can he get it to Rizzo and the bass
comes through and goes in and g2 s on
the board T's in the ceiling you can
watch him oh I don't want to get out
when he hit it he waited too little
class ii used in foods push it over to
Rizzo who gets up for the tight end
they've had a few leads in the series
but have not been able to hold on to any
and Nick now again they are down and
sold out no Mike give it this mat with
the read off of this look at this double
tap in the air for Mitchell to pass to
back yeah there's one of those
situations if you started to see a
little bit last game rogue is starting
to get comfortable they're not afraid to
make these challenges so they're trying
to pull them out of defense one by one
that's why they keep going through that
backboard but I think it was one too
many on that last Drive corrupted Oh
grub dish you'll find the hole in the
defense here off of the pass from chrome
and that's flight West with the lead I
had a feeling this will be close but not
that close 12 chrome just feeding
torment for that and then corrupted
without any hesitation skipping back
into the box minute 20 left fly West out
by - meeting - oh God these guys the
monster plays the climate's putting up a
brilliant pass from squishy foot get I
guess all that all right cool let me get
the triple yeah he's in a position to
shoot a feel
towards the back for candy DoubleTap
this it puts it down like he's done it a
million times before and it's a one-goal
game when you are this good at putting
it towards the backward and following
you're essentially giving yourself a
guaranteed goal of a trick save right
there it's gonna try to flick that one
stray oh that's gonna go in that is it
going Gibbs are you gonna fit this idiom
tally mark for how many I've been I've
been a place that was clean need to stop
moving themselves for his crumpled Jeep
I'm not just that look at how far that
Jeter came off the wall for this drape
down to corrupt it Oh window now the
field in classics it just goes in off
the touch from what the mere unable to
make the clear they're back up again his
touch though a touch long credible crow
missed the boost that's gotta be
crushing he could have had that buddy a
lot of neutral play going for both games
like we always talked about just feeling
each other on that first game oh man I
shot I did not expect that all the
double touch off that back wall able to
pick that one up Timmy just sets it for
him he says all right cool when you're
speaking yet no
sends it up chemic with the redirect
over the top play like a team that wants
to be number one in north america cloud9
temple heed gimmick that was absolutely
beautiful
nobody had to play that one just a
little bit too quickly cookies carpet
time Garrett just over the top of one
okay try to get over to there it goes
into the corner see there boy but it
does work Garrett gets that initial
touch off the gel but he still has it
left so he jumps again and it's a flip
to even further downfield it's a
breakdown and IG see something from that
but the first thing that needs gets
pulled out the harm and extend it's
gonna become even more difficult for
them Jake to Guerra and that is gonna be
two now beautiful one - jacob plays that
nice and soft up to himself whether
intentional or not but when he does
afterwards is crucial lands on the wall
Amelie gets up - thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button